the legacy of that shield is
complicated
the world
is upside down
people need something to get behind
they need the symbol
so what's our plan
so no plan
great
what's going on in that cyborg brain of yours you
don't want to know oh yeah i can see it working
gear's turning oh they're malfunctioning
they're on fire god i hate you
moving to our next series for disney
plus which launches this coming march
the falcon and the winter soldier features two
recognizable superheroes last seen together in
the final moments of avengers endgame sam
wilson aka the falcon is played by anthony
mackie and bucky barnes the winter soldier
is played by sebastian stan the falcon in the
winter soldier is a cinematic experience it's a
marvel studios movie played out over six episodes
and now here for the first time is an exclusive
look at the falcon in the winter soldier
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new marvel falcon and winter
soldier trailer we have episodes coming up really
early in 2021 so i'll explain what's going on with
the release date the episodes and how this crosses
over with the movies and the other bigger stuff in
marvel phase 4 in marvel phase 5 that it's setting
up through mutants weapons plus program weapon x
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i'll do a disney plus
giveaway when we get ready for episodes of
Wandavision that's going to be the first series
to release in january falcon in winter soldier
is going to premiere march 19th so there'll be
a couple weeks break between the end of the wanda
vision episodes and the finale in the beginning of
falcon and winter soldier because they're still
finishing the editing and post-production on
falcon and winter soldier episodes but as you can
see from the trailer footage there's going to be
lots of easter eggs for all the captain america
movies obviously because it's a captain america
based series going back to marvel phase one the
super soldier program becoming the weapons plus
program via thunderbolt ross and all the hulk
movies we get a really good look at their new
costumes and if you guys didn't know florence
pugh's yelling a beloved black widow is supposed
to show up during the series she's also supposed
to be featured during the hawkeye series which
makes sense because hawkeye black widow characters
kind of go together and she's becoming the new
version of black widow they're sort of passing the
mantle during the course of the black widow movie
and as you see them travel to a bunch of different
locations through the trailer one of the other
really cool easter eggs for upcoming movie they
just announced is the fantastic four movie if
you can believe it they go to latvia during this
series so i'm not expecting doctor doom to show
up or anything like that but it's them just
laying the track work to do the fantastic four
if you didn't see it i just posted my loki trailer
video there's a lot of that similar fantastic four
easter eggs in the background going on during
that so like the fantastic four won't show up
during the loki's series but they're laying a lot
of track work for king the conqueror who is a big
character to the fantastic four because he's
nathaniel richards he's the descendant of reed
richards so is them just doing a lot of fantastic
four stuff in the background before they actually
release the movie thankfully marvel revealed that
they are making a brand new rebooted fantastic
four movie they haven't announced the cast yet
but it's being directed by spider-man director
john watts who's done all the mcu spider-man
films probably because there's going to be some
spider-man crossover with fantastic four everyone
start getting hyped for the amazing bagman in the
mcu but the falcon winter soldier trailer starts
with the same museum display from captain america
winter soldier that featured all the captain
america classic costumes the howling commandos and
the history of their teams from world war ii but
now it's falcon visiting it and he's looking and
you see all the modern captain america costumes
because since the avengers end game ending scene
of captain america coming back and passing the
shield to him he's effectively retired but old
man cap is still alive he hasn't died or anything
like that when falcon says the legacy of the
shield is complicated it's a reference to a bunch
of different things the series is going to feature
a ton of different characters who at one time in
the comics wore the mantle of captain america and
used the shield but i believe in this instance
he's referring more to the isaiah bradley stuff
so isaiah bradley is the og captain america right
after steve rogers cap disappeared in the ice in
the first captain america movie this scene of them
just hanging out at this house down in the south
just seems like them chilling out after the ending
of avengers end game like they just want to lay
low for a little while i believe all this stuff is
taking place around madrapur which is an island in
the south china sea featured in the x-men comics
there'll be a few x-men mutants easter eggs but
that's mostly going to be the weapons plus weapon
x program stuff and some of the locations that
show up in the x-men comics i'm not expecting the
new wolverine to be featured or anything like that
all this is really just early marvel phase 4 stuff
setting up and influencing what's to come next
which is all the big mutants and x-men stuff when
you see that squad of justice soldiers spelled
with a z and bucky's talking about the world being
upside down things be really complicated i believe
this is probably something related to thunderbolt
ross the world security council because most of
them look american someone blows up a lab near a
bunch of shipping containers the lab is probably a
reference to the super soldier serum someone is
able to bring back during the series the super
soldier serum itself or a version of it the newest
version is one of the macguffins of the series
somebody is able to resurrect the super soldier
program and it becomes a big threat so that's just
one aspect of the series flag smasher is supposed
to be one of the main villains next to baron zemo
so obviously we see baron zemo during the trailer
but i believe this girl who will probably seem
familiar that's wearing the mask with the hand
print on it i believe she's either related to
flag smasher or she herself will wind up being
flag smasher the whole thing with that character
is that flax smashers this classic captain
america villain who's all about tearing down
world governments with the idea that it will bring
the world together in common cause under a single
banner the comic book version is kind of silly so
i'm assuming they're toning it down just a little
bit changing it for the mcu version the whole
thing with baron zemo though as you see during
the footage like you see bucky talking to him
obviously they have a complicated history together
i believe that baron zemo is slated for their
eventual thunderbolts team up so my assumption
is from the footage and the way they're portraying
the character just the way he's coming off
is that through the course of the series baron
zemo will wind up helping them stop flag smasher
and in the process thunderbolt ross will offer him
a chance to knock off some time from his sentence
by joining the thunderbolts eventually then you
see falcon getting his new upgraded wingsuit
while they're just hanging out and buggy trying to
get him to answer the hero's call convincing him
to take out the shield like kav wanted talking
about being the same type of symbol the cap was
for people to get behind while they're also
showing you the footage of us agent captain
america being rolled out in this big celebration
i've already done a couple videos about the us
agent version of captain america so technically
the shield is the property of the us government
and thunderbolt ross wants a new quote-unquote
symbol but one that he can control a new captain
america that will do whatever he tells him
to do and that winds up being us agent but if
you've seen any of the behind-the-scenes footage
u.s agent is kind of like the stabbier darker
version of captain america the scene of baron
zemo seems like he's standing at a monument to
sokovia probably thinking about his dead wife
and child wearing his trademark purple outfit
from the comics he does wear the purple hood
from the comics as well we get a big montage
of action scenes we see winter soldier on his new
bike they did tease that they would reveal some
of the other special abilities that his vibranium
arm has that shuri designed for him they said that
during infinity war and avengers end game there
was a whole bunch of stuff that it does that we
just never saw because they never had time to get
to it then you get that funny scene of them on
the plane together bucky saying what's the plan no
plan great awesome as they jump out the back then
they just show off a montage of falcon trying to
evade all those missiles and the canyons using his
new wingsu just kind of showing you what he can
do because they have much more time to spend on it
then after a montage of a bunch of fight scenes
they get that funny tag scene of them just making
fun of each other like captain america civil war
just being two dudes falcon referencing bucky's
cyborg brain which is a nice call back to black
panther and shuri helping deprogram all of his
hydra brainwashing and commands so i believe when
the series picks up as of the ending of avengers
end game 2 all that's gone he can't be controlled
using the red book and the commands anymore
and even though she's not really featured a lot
during this trailer footage sharon carter came
back for the series emily van camp is a pretty
big character she'll be helping them out take
down flag smasher so just a reminder falcon
and winter soldier episodes starting march 19th
there'll be six episodes total they're calling
it a mini mini-series so i don't know if there's
going to be a season two or not same thing for
Wandavision but supposedly they are going to do
a loki season two they haven't completely revealed
all those plans but there'll be three to four of
these different series per year 2021 is going
to have four of them so it'll be Wandavision
then falcon and winter soldier episodes then
10 episodes of marvel's what if series and
then hawkeye episodes at the end of the year but
if you spotted any big easter eggs that i didn't
mention during the video just write them below in
the comments i'll be doing more trailer videos for
the marvel phase 4 trailers they dropped this past
week and the star wars disney plus trailers for
the upcoming stuff like star wars obi-wan kenobi
hayden christensen coming back as darth vader
the mandalorian ahsoka spin-off series so
as long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see all those videos when
i post them everyone click here to re-watch my
loki trailer video a billion more times and
click here for my full mandalorian season 2
episode 7 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!